joining me now is Tulsi gabbard former
Hawaii congresswoman a 2020 candidate
for the Democratic nomination for
president and a Fox News contributor
Tulsi this censorship game is is
political here
um explain why this is ultimately so
concerning especially given that
quotation form from Orwell that if you
edit edit the past long enough people
forget that there was a truth and the
new edit becomes the truth for Next
Generation
yeah Laura there are so many reasons why
this is dangerous and the fact that is
it is political is is exactly the
problem this is not a Democrat or
Republican issue we need common sense
and honesty and we unfortunately have
politicians who are neither and they are
directly trying to politicize this issue
for their own political gain in the next
election uh there are there are two
distinct issues here that we're dealing
with number one is parents who are
taking action to protect their kids from
activists who are trying to sexualize
them in ages as young as four years old
I think when people actually read and
hear the the explicit sexual content in
these books it is absolutely shocking
the second issue here is censorship of
views are they political views
philosophical views or views of history
and trying to keep information away from
the American people and what we're
seeing here is the dishonesty of
politicians who are who are equating
these two now I believe the American
people of Common Sense and the American
people are smart enough to see through
this insanity and to recognize what
danger and threat this poses to our kids
but frankly to our democracy we're this
open flow of information for Americans
is is critical well how do you know the
truth and what is not true if it's
constantly being edited for whatever
faddish sensibility you know is in Vogue
at any given day so I mean does the New
York Times want it's old articles that
it wrote edited probably not Tulsi right
I mean they're going to be off limits
they get to keep their old account
naturally
that you know you were talking about
we're living in like this this upside
down world where good is bad and bad is
good and we have a situation where these
people those who are part of this
mainstream so-called woke establishment
they want to treat adults they want to
treat us as the American people like
children and tell us hey we know what's
best for you we're going to control what
information you can see and read and
hear what you can say what information
is is acceptable versus what is
misinformation but when it comes to our
kids they want to treat our kids like
adults and as as President Biden said
the other day that he believes our kids
should have unfettered access to all
books including those who are targeting
the most young and vulnerable in our
kids with explicit child pornography and
sexual content that you couldn't even
put on the air it is so atrocious and in
this extends of course to racial
racializing curricula as well so America
it has to be portrayed as systemically
racist so it's you know it's a new
founding of America under a new
radical's vision of what America was and
continue to continues to be to this day
so it's ultimately Tulsi very
pessimistic about our country and all
the blessings we have even with all our
mistakes in the past
that's true the American people should
be exposed to and have access to the
truth and the facts all of them about
our history we can learn from lessons
from the past and actually work towards
that Vision our Founders had for this
country that's what it means to be an
American to have this open free
Marketplace of ideas to be able to
gather the information treat each other
with respect have our leaders treat us
like adults rather than children and
recognize we have the ability to make
our own decisions we don't need the
government dangerously we don't need the
government trying to do that for us or
or the woke sensors as their proxies and
these publishing houses and Tulsi you
know turning to something we hit with
Congressman Massey last night President
Biden is now trying a new tactic to
reauthorize that controversial
surveillance program in public and in
private Administration officials are
stressing the need to track Mexican
cartels and their Chinese suppliers and
their push for Congress to re-up fisa
section 7 102 specifically before it
expires at the end of the year so Tulsi
they want to use the cartels because
they think okay we created this problem
with the cartels now we're going to try
to you know reauthorize fisa now is that
those all Noble intentions no
possibility for abuse right you know no
of course not of course they have the
best of intentions what I see when they
when I see them doing this is they have
declared the war against terrorism to be
over which was the reason that section
702 and the secret fisa Court was put in
place in the first place along with the
Patriot Act that we've shown has has
they have shown has been abusing our
civil liberties in privacy for so long
but they say the war on terrorism is
over and so now who's the bad guy that's
that they have to use as an excuse to
continue to abuse their power and
violate our rights and civil liberties
it's it's uh they're they're exposing
themselves and their own hunger for
power and how much they don't care about
the Constitution they don't care about
civil liberties they don't care about
the American people in our rights it's
all about themselves and their own
corruption and Tulsi Republicans who are
thinking of reauthorizing that it's
usually the establishment Bush type so
what's your message for them tonight
listen remember the oath that you took
when you when you entered that office
you swore an oath to the Constitution
that means something and you need to
uphold that oath to the American people
when you when you do things like this in
the name of so-called National Security
and you you go against that oath you go
against the civil liberties of the
American people doesn't matter how much
lip service you give to freedom and
democracy and civil liberties your
action and your vote is what actually
counts and we are watching Tulsi thank
you so much have a great weekend hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else